130 miles south of the Arctic Circle
the ground is blanketed in snow and ice
even in May the landscape is more water
than land beautiful pristine and sixty
million years ago a scene of utter
devastation all of a sudden in this
undisturbed Tundra there's ash
everywhere it looks like the apocalypse
and there's these holes too you know
down to the bowels of the earth uric
Innokin is a geophysicist at the Diavik
diamond mine in Canada's Northwest
Territories which is operated by Rio
Tinto the holes he's describing were
made when molten rock or kimberlite
squeezed through cracks in the oldest
rock on earth and exploded spectacularly
it's going to be going kilometers up in
the air it's going to wipe everything
out and then it's just going to stop
when conditions are just right diamonds
will hitch a ride with kimberlite at
Diavik one of those diamonds was a
whopper it ended up where most
kimberlite diamonds in the subarctic end
up after glaciers scour the land beneath
a lake we knew the diamonds were under
there but we needed to be in dry
conditions the only way we could do that
is by building dikes around them and
then draining all of the water within
those dikes to million metric tonnes of
ore are processed here annually last
year that yielded 6.4 million carats but
since the mine began there's only been
one Foxfire
every
probably every half a minute
is going to be a diamond coming
chances of a large diamond
Foxfire is 187 point seven carats
because a diamond that size was
considered so unlikely to be found the
mine is configured to crush anything
over an inch
Foxfire escape to crushers turning
sideways and slipping through a screen
to end up in one of these buckets
it's a long way from a bucket in
Canada's north to Fifth Avenue where New
York buyers are getting their first
glimpse of Foxfire we have two clients
who are very interested in this diamond
one of them is interested in keeping it
in its in its current form they want to
keep it as a piece of rough and the
other one is very interested in making
it into a pendant a pendant that could
be more than a hundred carats uncut
Foxfire is expected to fetch between
five and ten million dollars that's a
fraction of the 63 million dollars this
813 carat diamond found by luc ara
diamonds in Botswana sold for earlier
this month but with only a handful of
diamond mines operating in Canada and
Diavik scheduled to close in 2024 it's
hoped buyers will pay a premium for a
piece of North American history they
call this the barren lands that a
diamond like Foxfire destined to be a
beautiful indulgence could be found here
beneath a frozen lake on one of the
harshest landscapes on earth is
something of a miracle odds are it won't
happen twice Danielle Bokova
Bloomberg at the Diavik mine in Canada's
Northwest Territories